Vì kế bẩy tháng của năm 2019, tổng giả trị xuất khẩu 5.3, ước đặt 1.5 phẩy tảm tị đủ lầm Mỹ
tăng bẩy phy năm phần chăm sót của kì của năm 2019.
Trong số đỏ trị xuất khẩu các mặt hàng lúc 3 đặt 1.2 phẩy 2.2 tị đủ lầm Mỹ
tăng 2 phẩy tư vấn chăm.
Trần quên đặt 1 trong năm 2020, tăng vào ngày ba phẩy 2.3.
Thì xảm đặt sấu phẩy tảm bẩy 1.2 tị đủ lầm Mỹ tăng 2 phẩy bẩy tảm bẩy tảm bẩy tảm bẩy tảm bẩy tảm.
Mốt phẩy chiến phần chắc tì phần tiếp sau đó là hoặc kì với mười chiến phần chăm.
Vân định bà là sấu phẩy tảm phần chăm.
Trong mười tháng tị xuất khẩu các mặt hàng lúc 3, chủ lực tế tục gì dành sự phần hoa
sau dễ trong kì nhóm dấu qua thật tiêu và hạt điều tì dưới gỷ đà tăng trưởng
bây giờ a chỉ xuất khẩu.
Thì nhóm mặt hàng trình thống như cà phy và cầu su trẻ và sánh thì vẫn xuất giảm.
Một gió giá xuất khẩu bình quân giá hoặc yu câu tại các tị trình lớn chưa phục của hành toàn.
Mười bà nhất là gió qua, vì kìm gạc in đặt mốn phẩy tảm bẩy tảm bẩy tảm bẩy tảm bẩy tảm bẩy tảm bẩy tảm bẩy tảm bẩy tảm
tăng 2 bẩy tảm phẩy chiến phần chăm.
Sau vào phức cuộc kiện trong hàng bẩy tảm bẩy tảm bẩy tảm có tăng trình cà nhất trong nhóm đông sản chú lực.
Mặc dù khối lượng xuất khẩu tăng mười phy tảm bẩy tảm bẩy tảm
con năm phẩy đúng 1 lòng tỷ đúng là Mỹ, con số này giảm bùi 1 phẩy hai phần chăm.
Rò giá xuất khẩu bình quân giảm mạch 1 xin phẩy chiến phần chăm.
Con khoảng 4,5 bẩy đúng là Mỹ trên một tấn, các thị trường chủ lực như đất,
y tà lia và nhat bà, đều viện mất giảm kìm ngạch trong khi Trung Quốc là điểm giảm
với mất tăng bẩy mười xấu phẩy 1 phần chăm.
Sất tổ gạo đàn 2 phẩy xấu mấy tựa đủ là Mỹ giảm sấu phy bẩy phần chăm dù sản lực
và đi nưu đã đi ngang tăng không phẩy năm phần chăm.
Môn nhận chủ yêu là giá xuất khẩu bình quân giảm mầy phép một phần chăm.
Con khoảng 5,5 bẩy Mỹ xấu phy xấu đủ là Mỹ trên một tấn,
kênh đất phy tụp là thị trường lớn nhất trong khi xuất khẩu sản chục Quốc thì tăng gấp hài.
Vên nhập khẩu thì bộ nông nhập và mỗi trường cho biết là giả chị nhập khẩu nông lập thị trường.
Đăng có giấu hiệu tăng chấp lại khi bẩy tăng,
hước tăng, mười phẩy tăng cho bỏ cục kì năm chấp.
Với tập kìm đặt bàn mút phẩy bẩy bà tỷ đủ là Mỹ.